[Applause]
what's going on fever fans I'm golden
boy coming it to you alive from the
Volta pitch here at EA play now I had a
blast actually hosting a FIFA Ultimate
Team Champions Cup a few weeks back but
that was FIFA 19 today we're here to
talk about FIFA 20 now if you caught the
brand new trailer that dropped this
morning you already know that volta
football is a new way to play returning
football to the street FIFA to the
streets like that all right now for
those of you who missed it let's take a
look give me a pass
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now in a bit I'm gonna be chatting with
Sam Rivera the lead producer at FIFA 20
about some of the new gameplay features
that are gonna be coming to FIFA 20 but
first we go across the pond last week
singer/songwriter and Fulham footballer
Chelsea Grimes caught up with some
special guests to give us the details on
volta football and the culture that
inspired it check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
we vaulted producer Jeff ensuite and
Manchester United and England legend Rio
Ferdinand to talk about a subject close
to my heart true football
[Music]
okay sir Rio we're here in London your
hometown cage football street football
what was your like memories and
experiences growing off did you play a
lot of it no this is where I grew up
this is exactly what I've done day in
day out
in there the fool never goes out of play
physically it's demanding you're forced
to almost have a personality and show
personality in there do that mean you
can't hide in there so I used to play in
the street with all the boys and it was
kind of the saying you know we bling out
to bounce it off heaven and I use the
walls on people's houses there's another
player
what was it for you that made you want
to bring it even into the game for us
it's a return to speed football for the
fifa franchise and we're really excited
about being able to you know be in
places like this you know where it's
rooted in the real people the real place
is authenticity creativity culture are
all things I wanted to bring to - volta
it's amazing that's what you can do in
both of those so that's part of that's
part of the detail in the gameplay so
you can do that at least my tricks are
this well just being able to be really
skillful with the ball of your feet you
know whether it's a classic futsal drag
or being able to play it off the wall to
yourself to beat your opponent or flick
it up over your head to create space for
an on goal can you use the classroom
like the professional savings absolutely
so obviously with it being FIFA we want
to make sure that authenticity is at the
forefront and so you can play with or
against the real players all the license
players that we have all the laces pubs
you can imagine playing Chelsea versus
Spurs in this London Cage
[Music]
the physical and technical much I played
on loads of different places where is it
to play on the gameplay so obviously
with Volta it's it's the world's game
and there's so many locations you can
play with from a rooftop in Tokyo to a
London cage like this or even an
underpass in Amsterdam so you know we
want to make sure that what we're
building is you know real to the space
the realest of the people was there a
lot craziest place you played football I
was actually in a camp in LA and I
played a bit of a bit of soccer there
which has soccer I've never played it
there before and the pitches are a lot
nicer than when I go play maybe in a
favela in Brazil I went to the World Cup
in Brazil my first one I didn't as a
pundit I managed to graduate of
revellers another look crazy room and
amongst that was just like a pitch in
the middle of it in a cage a bit like
here but just different setting what
type of football were you playing
we played whoever was there so you just
play with the numbers you've got if
there's free be free fine if it was far
besides not a problem so what's great is
that sportive being able to play 3v3
4455 playing with goalkeepers playing
without goalkeepers and you know playing
in a cage like this or playing futsal
you know with more authentic rules
I think Alta does a really good job of
representing the diversity of the game
not only the people but also in the game
style you can treat the wall like your
teammate passing to yourself or you can
be really skillful with the ball like
you know like these guys are being
[Music]
multiple Paul is such a diverse game and
familiars of people around the world
streets is their stadium so for you guys
like what are some of the fundamental
things that you take away from the
streets what translates to the stadium's
small-sided games freeze free versus
free farm asides I grew up in this
environment I think it enables you
definitely to be able to deal with
people 1v1 because in a game in a
stadium in front of thousands of fans
beam you're gonna have to deal with
someone wanna be one like this I will
figure spaces so do you get used to that
in this type of environment is I think
for a young player is key I'm gonna
personality not being afraid to try
something new yeah and obviously you
know eventually you can go and put it
onto the big stage I would think this is
like yeah you go and go and express
yourself I think definitely the word
that keyword express if you can express
yourself you see the best in everyone
thinking individually as a team you know
street football is for a lot of people
would spend a tional when it translates
to you know the stadiums for volta
that's that's kind of how we've built
the gameplay experience and so we're
really excited about what we can you
know represent and be able to represent
the Flair and the in the style that you
guys just talked about I think a lot of
people is well used to always associate
that skills and flair without the end
product I think that's what's great
about this game is it and products
always King
[Music]
you really want to know is can you
create female players absolutely I think
that's one of the biggest innovations
you can play male or female and they
play with each other as well and that's
an important part of what we're building
when you got implanted in their life one
turns up in a pair shorts boots can we
have like jeans that were cut downs like
I've got or you can have you know
t-shirts and shorts so you can have
jeans and long sleeves again a big thing
for us is you know being able to
establish the culture that is street
football through clothing through how
you look at your personal style you can
have short hair long hair you can have
tattoos no tattoos you can play with
trainers a lot of the time as well as
like at least you want to look good you
want to feel good play good in some of
its superstition like it's all of that
all in one if you can get that into a
game of chance further and translate
that into into the cage you got it made
that's a big part of both of football
just being able to represent the people
as they are you know we want it to be
authentic want to be diverse you know we
want it to be cultural and creative and
a lot of that is you know how you equip
yourself and how you carry yourself and
how you represent yourself in the game
thank you so much Rio it's been a
pleasure I can't wait to play Volta so
I'll see it in the cage well there you
have it Volta football pretty cool stuff
there now I can't wait to get my hands
on it later this summer but to talk to
us about the exciting new gameplay
updates and innovations that are gonna
be coming 5420 we have FIFA lead
gameplay producer Sam Rivera here
standing by Sam welcome thanks Alex is
great thank you thank you yeah all right
all right
pleasure to have you here my friend out
here's Dale I knew this coming into this
when they asked me to do this gig I was
like listen this is gonna be a tricky
one
right cuz FIFA has a very passionate
community I know this I experienced this
firsthand when I hosted that foot
Champions Cup and you and I we talked a
lot about how important it's been for
you to engage with the audience with the
fans with the community on FIFA 20 s
development so why don't we dive into
that tell me about that process and how
the community played a role in making
this game a reality for you all
absolutely community feedback is a big
deal for us
the combination of community feedback
and football itself is what inspires us
every year to keep innovating and to
create the most authentic and fun
experience we can and we know we have a
big community so this year we actually
talked to over 3,000 players from pro
players to new players casual players
soccer players and because we know this
is a two-way conversation we released an
important pitch notes article at the end
of May where we explain a little bit
more about how we approach community
feedback so we listen to things like
shooting inconsistencies or AI defending
and this feedback together with our
drive to create a more authentic
football experience led us to develop a
new feature set that comes together as
football intelligence okay all right so
catchphrases are all well and good right
but let's dive into this right because I
want to be able to dive deeper into what
all this means for the player what does
football intelligence mean for the folks
that are gonna be playing in a few
months
sure football intelligence is a
combination of features that improve the
three main components of the match on
the ball of
and the wall itself and this year were
innovating in those three areas on the
wall we're enhancing the one-on-one
moments by giving you new attacking and
defending tools off the wall with a rear
keytective game flow we're giving
players more time and space on the ball
and for the ball itself we have a brand
new ball physics system that elevates
Delton TCG on every touch okay so you
mentioned off the ball first that's
something that you know I'm assuming
you're talking about computer control
players there and this is a big topic
within the community I know how those
players interact with you when you're
playing the game so yeah I mean what
what is off the ball what does that mean
for us yes so off the ball if there's
something that is really going to change
how the game plays is their rear
connected game flow this new game flow
was designed to give more time and space
to the dribbler and create more
one-on-ones a one-on-one is one of the
most interesting parts of football to
watch or to play if you actually play
the sport and in FIFA is gonna be the
time where user skill is going to make a
difference and while we're creating more
one-on-ones we're also encouraging more
user control defending and we are
reducing the amount of AI defensive
support that you get from your teammates
okay all right so you want to really
want to like influence the player to be
engaged in that process yeah and I know
it seems like we're kind of just like
throwing questions out here but you know
III cuz I'm curious I'm really
interested right when I have a
controller in my hand you know what what
does this feel like you know is there
what extra space is being created with
this more player controlled approach yes
first of all the rear connected game
flow allows us to encourage smart
technical build-up based on skill so
when you score a goal you feel like you
really work for it and because you
mentioned space yes spacing is actually
one of the biggest benefits of this
system you will see how your teammates
spread around the pitch in a more
authentic way allowing you to read the
game better and also giving you new ways
for you to create your own scoring
chances and visually does the game looks
much more like like real football yeah
so my teammates are gonna be way more
helpful for me cuz lord knows I need
that alright I think you know a lot of
us feel the struggle there but now what
about the player me right as I'm as I'm
playing this game
what new tools do I have that I could
put out there on the pitch yes so
football is all about the decisive
moments on the wall and now that we're
encouraging those moments we're also
giving players that tools to make sure
those moments are in their control
there's four features that I want to
talk about composed finishing strafe
dribbling control tackling and the new
penalty kicks and free kicks all right
so four big topics yeah let's just dive
into this compose finishing what do you
mean by that sure we receive feedback
from the community regarding the
difficulty to finish in front of goal
okay so in FIFA 20 with the new compose
finishing you're going to experience
more clinical and consistent shooting
when you're in a one-on-one with the
keeper for example and if you try a more
difficult shot let's say a volley from
outside of the box then you're going to
have more chances to to miss so overall
we are improving the fundamentals of
shooting to provide a more authentic
experience and we also listen to
feedback about time finishing and that
we are very confident that the changes
that I just mentioned to the
fundamentals of shooting in addition to
some tweaks that we are doing to the
actual time finishing mechanic are going
to give you a more satisfying shooting
experience whether you time your shot or
not we are actually just releasing
another pitch news article about this
topic you want to know more information
you can check it online okay so a whole
topic just on this just alone which is
very dedicated there now you also
mentioned another attacking tool which
was strafe dribbling so how is this now
gonna play a role in how I play out good
question so we are reinventing the
strafe dribbling mechanic okay these two
lots more dimensioning attack giving you
more control more precise and not yell
control of the ball when dribbling and I
would say this tool is great to lure
your opponent in and then when he's
getting closer
use your players agility speed and skill
to beat that defender so if it wasn't
any indication though you know I I'm
gonna be on defense quite a bit Oh we'll
see because of that as a defender now
continuing to just run through these
tools these new gameplay additions that
are coming to it what about on the
defensive front yes to counter the
attacking tools we also need to bring
some innovation into defending the new
control tackling system which uses the
sophistication from the
active touch system from last year is
going to improve your players tackling
ability to ensure you win possession
back more often than ever when you
tackle in the right context okay and
then the most intense nerve-wracking
moment I add in any game of FIFA me and
my boy Rob we went this is a everyday
thing for us penalty kicks what changes
are you making the penalty kicks we have
brand new penalty kicks and free kick
systems okay so first of all the aiming
mechanics are completely different and
more accessible but obviously we're
keeping some elements of skill in there
to make sure there's enough depth in the
mechanics for those that want to be
masters on those on those systems and
for example in free kicks you're gonna
have full control of the spin that you
apply to the ball and that's going to
create your trajectory so you can do
side spin top spin no spin or a
combination of them and that's gonna be
based on how you swing your right stick
and then you will see the trajectory so
you can go around the wall you can go
over the wall you can do a knuckle shot
for example ultimately these systems are
more they're more fun but do you have
more control so that you feel okay it's
more rewarding and juice basically you
swing your a stick and then you see the
tractor being created and that's that's
the cool part so you know for like us
FPS gamers out there maybe that's
something that and I can actually be
good at you know I hit the right stick
that's awesome alright so on the ball
talked off the ball but the ball that is
the most essential part of the beautiful
game so what's new with the ball we have
a brand new ball physics system and the
bull is at the center of every match and
the innovation that we're bringing to
the ball this year just gives you a more
authentic experience of you know yeah so
we rewrote how the ball behaves on every
player contact on every bounce on every
interaction and how spin affects the
trajectory of a shot pass or cross so
what you will see is more realistic
realistic player deflections more
realistic bounces and if you do a shot
let's say a finesse shot you will see
maybe more curved you do a lace shot you
will see a like a dipping trajectory a
rising trajectory there's more variety
in general so the entire Viva experience
feels fresh because of this new ball
physics is trying to get that ball to
bounce in fun ways
create some interesting moments added
especially for a lot of our top players
out there now I know that a lot of fans
I'm sure are gonna be very excited to
try out these new features and since you
have the eyes and ears of a ton of FIFA
fans right now
floors yours anything else you want to
say to this community yes so the
features that I just talked about are
very important but there are many other
changes that we're doing in FIFA 20 and
a lot of them are based on community
feedback one of them is space we know
that sometimes slower defenders can
catch up with faster dribblers so we're
tweaking pace in FIFA 20 doesn't mean
that the entire game is gonna be based
on player speed but it just means that
player physical attributes are gonna be
slightly more important we're doing
something very similar for strength and
finally for those players that have
mastered the skill moves
we're obviously tuning some of them
let's say like a kata we're adding new
ones or if you like to change multiple
skill moves in a row then you will get a
more realistic outcome we're working on
those you tell me that text can't like
busts out like we'll see what you will
see new behaviors our text will still
find a way text will still find where
well thank you so much man I really
appreciate it now wanker players get
their hands on FIFA 20 so it's gonna be
easy sorry September 27th okay and
there's some good news if you have e
access your subscribe to you access you
can get hands on and September 19th Wow
okay and then of course you know EA
access coming appears or exactly that's
good news of ps4 fans will also be able
to play fifa September 19th
alright look at that there and of course
all those details can be found online so
don't forget about that it is a hot day
out here we've been talking FIFA I've
been having a blast and Sam thank you so
much man give it up for Sarah Berra once
again he can thank you awesome stuff now
don't forget if you're in LA come down T
EA play
chow if you 420 for yourself or come
watch some great street football
competition at our custom volt to pitch
keep an eye out because the FIFA team
has a lot more to come between now and
September they'll be posting deep dives
on the pitch notes platform you get more
info on gameplay
career mode pro clubs volta and because
we all know you want to talk about it
FIFA Ultimate Team to keep an eye out
for those I'm golden boy thanks so much
for watching see you later
[Applause]